this was a spectacular show North Korea
revealed one of its most secret science
to the bird then took it to pieces Sky
News was the only UK broadcaster present
at the demolition but what you see in
North Korea isn't always what you get
[Music]
I'll close with the regime we played a
cat-and-mouse game a struggle between
what we wants to film and what they
wanted to show don't take pictures here
the dismantling of the test site and
Bulgaria is evidence North Korea claims
of its peace-loving ways proof of its
sincerity what happened at Hungary then
is about what denuclearization really
means and about what happens next
it's rare for North Korea to allow
journalists in at all let alone to visit
a site at the heart of its nuclear
program from the beginning our trip was
an exercise in media management at
Beijing Airport foreign journalists were
waiting to film answer then we're in the
hands of the North Koreans
they were determined to present the
calculator view of the country from the
moment we boarded the Air Koryo flight
one sat on the east coast of the country
ours was only the third ever
international flight to land him in
arrivals our bags were emptied and
searched item by item officials
confiscated our satellite phone and a
dosimeter a device to measure how much
nuclear radiation the body absorbs the
test site was perfectly safe we were
told therefore we could have no need of
it afterwards we met our government
minder a man from Pyongyang who
preferred the term guide he would keep
watch over us at all times and told us
not to film him we were encouraged to
film the gleaming terminal then once an
was mainly famous for military drills
and missile launches now North Korean
leader Kim jong-un is rebranding it as a
tourist hub this is the image the regime
wants to present to the world clean
modern and ready for foreign money a
show home for its post summer future
usually when you come up an airport
after a long flight you get out you have
to fight for a cab there's loads of
people bustling around we're here
waiting around I just want to show you
one thing come out here this is an
airport International Airport and have a
listen to this absolutely nothing the
same went for our hotel recently
renovated the smell of fresh paint
overpowering a likeness of a luxury
resort we explored the rest of the
development or we tried to okay you have
to wait there don't take pictures
afterwards we were threatened with
expulsion for filming on the beach there
was little else to do while we waited a
day and a half for a council train ride
suddenly though we were given an hour to
pack our kits and bought a bus for the
train we drove through once our any
brief glimpse at normal life in North
Korea even as we were kept under close
watch on the bumpy mainly empty roads we
didn't see another car army backs for
soldiers conscripted to build the new
tourist hotspot children on their way
home from school people to work we
stared out and they stared back a bus
drove right onto the platform of the
sealed-off train station we were told
not to film and ordered hastily on board
the carriages of our train were staffed
by soldiers of the Korean People's Army
ahead a four hundred kilometer journey
through the night into the mountains we
just had a cup of horns now it looks
like we're off 11 hours to ponder II all
the window bones were pulled shut we
were ordered not to open them
but we filmed some of this rarely-seen
countryside as we started it was
certainly claustrophobic we were
completely under official control but
also in its way bizarre that evening in
the dining car we were treated to a
lavish 10 course banquet showcasing the
best of Korean cuisine lobster goes
[Music]
early next morning we awoke to find all
the window blinds have been opened still
that didn't mean we were allowed to film
we were repeatedly ordered to stop
we've just arrived here at Jerry the
station 11 hour journey we're getting
our briefing now and I'm gonna head into
the mountains Hungarian since 2006 the
North Koreans have detonated six nuclear
weapons all of them in tunnels
underneath these mountains paradoxically
this nuclear test facility was the only
place in the country we were allowed to
film freely this they were more than
happy to show here to greet us the
deputy director of North Korea's nuclear
weapons Institute a general he proudly
displayed a step-by-step guide to what
we'd see explosions would collapse the
tunnels seal their entrances and destroy
administrative buildings inside the
tunnels were rigged to blow explosives
but front and center for our benefit I
was told these bags contain plastic
explosives the viewing platforms too had
been built specially for us
they were a long trek up the
mountainside and then we waited for the
explosion
in total we saw the entrances to three
tunnels collapse the wooden buildings
that surrounded them were also
demolished
several North Korean officials I spoke
to made the same point why do people say
this is sure why do they doubt our
sincerity this is what's left of the
entrance to the northern tunnel where
they had conducted five nuclear tests
all robots been taken down but they were
very quick to declare there had been a
complete success
after those explosions you look around
it's journalists here it's not weapons
inspectors they're the ones we're the
ones who've been sent in to verify
whether indeed this nuclear test site is
being dismantled as rocks still tumble
down the mountains the general took the
stage declaring the site closed the
dismantling had been transparent I tried
to find out more North Korean kernels
like this one aren't used to taking
questions your deputy director talked
about transparency how can we verify
that the tunnels inside have also been
shot he told us that as we could see
very clearly with our own eyes the
explosions came from the inside that
means we've placed explosives inside the
tunnel and exploded them at the same
time and will there be other people who
can go and check after us well I'm not
expert but really it was impossible to
find the truth out here in no other
place in the world does the regime
control information so tightly unlike
the subjects of that regime though we
could leave and try to find our own
answers the mantra is trust but verify
back in Beijing working with experts
from 38 north so this is actually our
first ground view of not montage
okay we've only ever seen it from
satellite imagery for years they've been
analyzing satellite pictures to
understand North Korea's nuclear program
[Music]
first it's important to remember that
this was an active nuclear test site so
this is the last tunnel going inside
again obviously got the explosives front
and center but it's different from the
other tunnels here right right so here
unlike the other tunnels you see the
wood scaffolding that's still up and so
it hasn't been finished with concrete
yet this is the tunnel that's actively
under construction we've seen them you
know logging wood from the mountainside
in order to you know build the
scaffolding has they've been going along
so it's really interesting to see this
inactive progress still so yeah the
other ones might have been we're not
museum pieces but maybe out of action as
a result of all the testing well this is
definitely still has the intention of
being used and that's the one they're
getting rid of right then there's the
nature of the explosions themselves so
you know it means that they did more
than just the entrance itself again
probably a little bit further in again
our best estimates is probably about the
first hundred meters so you know to
really seal the entrances of the tunnels
themselves so for them to go back in
certainly they could reacts k'v eight
that if they wanted to but it would take
some effort so when they're saying
that's the ceiling all these tunnels
they're making them an unusable that is
a matter of contention for some people
saying you could go in and do it
certainly you know these tunnels would
still be ready to use if they were to
reopen and again re excavate the
entrances it doesn't take that long and
that much effort if they really wanted
to rebuild a nuclear test site somewhere
else
and yes flimsy wooden buildings can be
reconstructed but that's missing the
point because they've destroyed a lot of
their administrative and support
structure if they were to go back and
try and reopen the site we would be able
to detect it because they would at least
they would need to rebuild at least part
of that support structure so you know
it's unlikely that they're going to use
this
any time soon but certainly it's not
irreversible but it is a good gesture to
kick-start the diplomatic process so
this was a performance but also a
promise one that can only be fulfilled
by further more significant steps if
none of what we saw at Bulgari is
irreversible everything now depends on
the summit between kim jeong-hoon and
donald trump the demolition will prove
to be either one of the first steps to
denuclearization were an impressive but
empty gesture trust but verify
you